[Musique]
dès son arrivée à La Réunion la première
ministre Elisabeth borne est la
délégation qui l'accompagne près de la
mesure d'un grand projet environnemental
pour notre territoire la gestion des
ressources en eau pour les régions
nord-est avec le projet Mireille l'état
soutiendra le département maître
d'ouvrage des grands aménagements
hydrauliques sur l'île à hauteur de 30
millions d'euros supplémentaires pour ce
projet de basculement des eaux pour
autant sur la micro-région est vous
allez me dire effectivement il pleut
beaucoup néanmoins là encore on a des
enjeux infrastructurés qui sont
extrêmement importants pourquoi parce
que c'est le secteur qui concentre le
maximum de coupure d'eau c'est le
secteur on a des enjeux extrêmement
importants de diversification agricole
les enjeux extrêmement importants de
remise en culture de friche les enjeux
de développement extrêmement important
la chef du gouvernement s'est ensuite
entretenu avec le président du
département au palais de la source
principalement sur l'accompagnement des
publics fragiles s'inquez pas de
supplémentaires verront le jour avec la
possibilité d'offrir 2000 places
supplémentaires en faveur des publics et
porteur de handicap je voudrais aussi
saluer l'implication du département à
l'égard de personnes âgées et évidemment
l'État souhaite soutenir l'engagement du
conseil départemental
on a pris l'engagement de finance et la
création ou d'extension de 5
établissements pour les personnes âgées
et donc c'est ce qu'on est en train de
faire avec les deux premiers lauréats
qui seront désignés dans les prochains
jours et les appels à projets qui seront
ensuite pensés sur des trois suivants
visite de terrain sur une exploitation
en agroforesterie à bois blanc pour la
chef du gouvernement accompagné du
ministre de l'Agriculture une journée
consacrée au monde agricole avec la
rencontre de la filière élevage sur
cette exploitation de Sainte-Rose
Elisabeth borne annonce un soutien
supplémentaire de l'État pour la filière
fruits et légumes ultramarine dans jeu
de souveraineté alimentaire qui est
aussi valable évidemment dans l'Hexagone
est important dans les outre-mer donc
moi j'ai pu rassurer les acteurs de des
différentes filières sur le fait
on va continuer à soutenir cette
diversification avec notamment des aides
pour tous les dossiers qui ont été
déposés et puis par ailleurs j'ai aussi
pu rassurer les acteurs des filières
fruits et légumes qui ont des surprises
à la crise énergétique et j'ai pu
annoncer qu'on allait débloquer une
enveloppe de 10 millions d'euros pour
les filières fruits et légumes dans les
outre-mer en fin de journée la première
ministre rencontre les acteurs
associatifs les responsables du
département et les brigades de
gendarmerie à la maison de protection
des familles ils échangent sur la
problématique des violences
intrafamiliales et des besoins
nécessaires dans ce domaine l'État
s'engage à la création de quatre
brigades de gendarmerie dont trois
spécialisés dans la lutte contre ces
violences départementales
nous-mêmes nous avons augmenté les
moyens termes de personnels dans tout ce
qui touche aux informations
préoccupantes nous travaillons à
recruter donc des travailleurs sociaux
dédiés à l'écoute et au dialogue mais
nous avons la chance madame la Première
ministre d'avoir un réseau un réseau
territorial qui accompagne les
collectivités en particulier nous
départements dans ces missions donc je
tiens à le dire à vous remercier mais à
vous dire aussi que j'entends le message
de déployer des moyens sur une période
beaucoup plus allongée que peu que
aujourd'hui ce samedi Elisabeth borne
s'est rendu au belvédère du Maïdo pour
échanger sur la valorisation des sites
naturels et de la préservation de
l'environnement à la Réunion il est
prévu également une requalification du
Belvédère global et sur le site nous
nous trouvons donc le grand belvédère on
améliorera l'accessibilité donc ce grand
belvédère deviendra accessible à tous
les publics y compris les personnes à
mobilité réduite la délégation
ministérielle prend ensuite la direction
de Saint le haut Pôle emploi pour la
signature d'une convention département
état sur le projet expérimentation de
France travail la Réunion est le seul
territoire d'outre-mer parmi 18 autres à
expérimenté cette action 22000
allocataires du RSA seront au cœur de ce
dispositif de retour à l'emploi la
Réunion on agit depuis 2017 on a fait
baisser le chômage de 7 points mais il
reste très élevé à 17% ont beaucoup plus
haut que au niveau national donc on doit
continuer à mobiliser tous les leviers
pour permettre
à chacun de retourner vers un emploi
c'est à la Réunion comme ça peut être le
cas dans l'Hexagone de pouvoir cumuler
le RSA avec un emploi saisonnier
vraiment l'idée c'est d'inciter au
retour à l'emploi par tout moyen voilà
c'est une expérimentation qui va nous
permettre département mais aussi les
offres services qui travaillent à
l'installation des publics tels que la
CAF ou l'emploi
l'émission locale de mieux coordonner
nos actions
[Musique]